[Musica]
Buongiorno a tutti
controcorrente il tema della giornata di
oggi che vede protagonisti ospiti di
creature internazionali giovani
imprenditori creatori e portatori di
innovazione In un mondo che è già
abbastanza all'avanguardia e dunque cosa
ci faccio io in mezzo a tutte queste
menti brillanti del panorama italiano Io
sono qui oggi per portare via una
riflessione una riflessione basata su
fenomeni sociali storico naturali
arricchiti dalla mia esperienza
personale in ambito
una riflessione su un tema molto
delicato che colpisce il territorio in
particolar modo ovvero il fenomeno del
pregiudizio
partiamo da una breve descrizione poi
andiamo più nel dettaglio
Ok la slide
Ecco qua dal Treccani pregiudizio idea
opinione concepita sulla base di
convinzioni personali e prevensioni
generali senza conoscenza diretta dei
fatti delle persone delle cose tale da
condizionare fortemente la valutazione
ed indurre quindi in errore Questa è la
definizione presente su uno tra i più
celebri vocabolari della lingua del bel
paese adesso che ne conosciamo il
significato Però cerchiamo di andare
oltre come e dove nasce Facciamo un
passo indietro ricongiungiamoci verso la
nostra natura animale
prendiamo come esempio la gazzella che
tenta Istintivamente la fuga dal leone
allo stesso modo
l'uomo proverà una generica ostilità nei
confronti dell'ignoto dello sconosciuto
della diversità
esso è parte del nostro curriculum
storico genetico frutto di secoli e
secoli di lotta e sopravvivenza al fine
di portare avanti la specie
Dunque l'essere umano tenterà l'attacco
o la fuga a discrezione della situazione
la socio biologia oltre alla poc'anzi
citata caratteristiche Individua
un'altra componente a contrasto della
precedente ovvero l'istinto di
solidarietà l'uomo tende a fare squadra
a lavorare in gruppo in armonia L'essere
in simbiosi l'uno con l'altro per
lavorare con Maggiore facilità e
migliorare la propria condizione di vita
Dunque abbiamo un equilibrio un
equilibrio in ciò che la bilancia
metaforica dove abbiamo il pregiudizio
che combattuto da questo istinto di
solidarietà quando non si riesce a
mantenere questo equilibrio si sfocia
negli stereotipi nella discriminazione
Se entrare in un tunnel dal quale è
molto difficile uscirne
adesso che abbiamo conosciuto la
tematica andiamo ad analizzare
all'interno del nostro territorio ed è
qui che entrerà il mio apporto vero e
proprio o meglio la mia esperienza
personale per i più informati non sarà
una novità e molti di voi lo avranno
colto quando mi sono presentato
chiaramente ci sono anche tante persone
che non sanno di cosa io stia parlando e
cioè che il mio cognome e la mia
famiglia non sono conosciuti lungo il
territorio per il più nobile dei motivi
dato che è presente nel 60 70 per cento
circa delle inchieste e delle indagini
mosse dalla direzione investigativa
Antimafia nel Cosentino Ciò ha
chiaramente avuto molte influenza sulla
mia persona soprattutto nei primi anni
della mia vita Mi sono sempre sentito
gli occhi puntati addosso con le persone
volte a puntare il dito per qualunque
cosa accadesse semplicemente per avere
L'unica colpa di essere nato in una
famiglia che non ho deciso io
col tempo ho imparato a combattere
queste sensazioni però allo stesso tempo
allo stesso momento ho portato tante
cicatrici lungo il percorso una di esse
risalente al primo giorno di scuola
media quando durante l'appello la
professoressa di tecnologia si soffermò
sul mio cognome e disse di Pupo tu tu
sei il figlio del carcerato giusto
ripetete con me immaginate lo scenario
dove primo giorno di scuola quindi il
nuovo ambiente nuovi professori nuovi
compagni soprattutto
un bambino di 10 anni in questo caso me
stesso
catapultato all'interno di questo nuovo
ambiente è un educatrice
che debutta con la suddetta affermazione
cosa può scaturire all'interno della mia
testa Se perfino i professori mi
ritraggono come tale Che colpa ho nel
nell'essere il figlio di
tante tante riflessioni e tante domande
che potevano portarmi a perdere fiducia
in me stesso a pensare che io non fossi
destinato ad altro che lo stesso destino
di chi mi ha preceduto fortunatamente
nel mio caso così non è stato perché
questo episodio ha generato in me un
trauma Positivo positivo di rete bene Sì
perché ha generato dentro di me una
fortissima voglia di rivalsa senza
precedenti ha generato dentro di me
l'ambizione nel cercare di diventare
impeccabile di smentire tutti quei
pregiudizi nel dimostrare appunto che io
non fossi quello che per come la società
mi dipingeva
Dunque partendo dal piano didattico
culturale fino a spaziare su tutte
quelle che sono le aree della vita
competizioni sportive esibizioni
musicali relazioni sociali e quant'altro
un altro episodio spiacevole che forse
mi ha provocato più dolore del
precedente risale al secondo anno di
liceo quando a 15 anni appena compiuti
Insomma crescendo arrivano le prime
fidanzatine le prime cotte tutti voi
avete avuto 15 anni in passato quindi
sapete bene a cosa Mi sto riferendo e
sapete benissimo cosa significa sentirsi
rifiutati da una persona partendo da
questo assunto immergiamoci nello
scenario dove un piccolo Michele
incuriosito invaghito dal genere
femminile inizia a stringere un rapporto
con una ragazza in particolare A
confidarsi sui suoi sui suoi lati più
intimi sulle sfaccettature della vita
privata si genera un rapporto si crea un
legame dell'empatia della complicità
al che dopo un po' di tempo decide di
rivelare i suoi sentimenti e la risposta
che riceve è la seguente Si mi piaci
però
non potrei mai uscire da sola con te
perché
i miei sanno che è la tua famiglia mi
taglierebbero le gambe
è chiaro che in quel momento le gambe le
atlete a me perché mi sono sentito
privato di un qualcosa che
per non avere colpe fondamentalmente
[Applauso]
questo episodio
questo episodio ha lasciato un enorme
ferita nella mia persona
per molti anni ma ha provocato diverso
dolore lì è nato il desiderio di voler
cambiare cognome una volta terminato il
liceo non pensavo che vi fosse altra
soluzione perché volevo iniziare da capo
cercare di rimuovere qualunque cosa che
potesse associarmi al legame anagrafico
con la mia famiglia
il punto di svolta è giunto qualche anno
dopo quando appena eletto rappresentante
come diceva Matteo Durante la
presentazione proprio del liceo Pitagora
Tra l'altro ho avuto l'occasione l'onore
di presentare un evento di importanza
regionale al quale erano presenti tutti
i neo dirigenti della provincia evento
destinato poi a finire sui giornali
locali
in basso a destra sono io a fianco
all'assessore Coreglia Corigliano e
vedere il mio nome che nel corso degli
anni aveva accompagnato solamente gli
articoli di cronaca nera trovarsi
finalmente riconosciuto con meriti e
complimenti Mi ha fatto capire tante
cose mi ha fatto capire che io non sono
destinato ad essere per sempre e
solamente il figlio di Giovanni di Pupo
per le persone che io posso
rivalorizzare il mio nome e che la gente
Dunque possa toccare con mano e avere
ben chiaro cosa significa andare
controcorrente
Questo è Michele oggi
oggi Michele fa parte di premessa su
questa parte del discorso non ho voluto
preparare nulla ho preferito che le
parole mi venissero spontaneo una volta
trovatomi qui sul tappeto rosso
oggi Michele fa parte di Alfa Alfa è
l'associazione studentesca più grande
dell'unical oggi Michele grazie ad alfa
ha trovato quella che è una seconda
famiglia una casa ha trovato un punto di
riferimento
in persone che
hanno creduto e che continuano a credere
in lui
oggi Michele come alfa è un punto di
riferimento per Michele È un punto di
riferimento per centinaia di studenti
all'interno del suo corso di laurea
all'interno del dipartimento e perché no
anche un po' di tutta l'unical Spero
oggi Michele archiviato per sempre il
desiderio di voler cambiare cognome
questo perché ed è rivolto in particolar
modo a chi vivendo una situazione simile
E sono certo di non essere l'unico visto
il territorio in cui abitiamo abbia
pensato che non ci sia speranza
possibilità Ricordatevi sempre che il
nostro cognome non dovrà mai essere una
vergogna perché
piuttosto che essere un marchio negativo
come ce lo dipinge la società e indice
delle difficoltà che abbiamo passato che
passiamo e che continueremo a passare
tutti i giorni alla nostra vita con
giusto inneggiando alla cultura al
sapere
all’innalzarvi al di sopra con la vostra
testa alla resilienza al non fermarvi di
fronte le critiche che aggiungerei sono
pure abbastanza insensate all'andare
controcorrente Grazie
[Applauso]
Michele